you know what I've never tried is the
blood facial thing where they take out
your blood and then they put it back in
your face that's like a little maybe too
extreme for me we got in the bag okay
[Music]
vibrator this is yeah you know I've
always wanted to open the box and see
what tennis coach I don't know maybe the
tennis coach you know with dead sexy
yeah I'm kind of into your tennis coach
maybe I have to practice you kind of go
Cabana with your tennis coach take it
home and you know see what it does no
because I'm making that you're such a
great like proponent for female
sexuality that's so exciting I think
it's really important I think it's a
really important subject
I think women feel much better and are
much happier and integrated when they're
having good orgasm
yeah I'm poised to do I close my eyes
and yeah good I know what this is dig
around the martini bath salts so if you
can't drink it baby take it exactly it's
not actually vodka or gin but these in
all seriousness these are the I cannot
and my day without a soap in one of
these yeah goop bath mm-hmm it's got
five different kinds of incredible salts
it's got essential oils it's really
meant to use like the healing powers of
essential oils to kind of bring you down
get your emotions back it's like a
drinking a martini but no uh you know
adverse effects on your liver it's above
like a whole Advent process for you
for me it is yeah it is I
I cannot it's weird I cannot sleep
unless I've had a hot bath are you
saying you like kids come in it's like I
said yeah I've got a little couch and
you know if they want to come in and
chat I'm in there you know I soak for a
good 20 minutes yeah okay oh this is the
best this is our shampoo it's Himalayan
sea salt scalp scrub and shampoo and it
makes your hair incredible and this is
pretty new product and it's already a
huge hit and this is amazing okay you're
the gift that keeps on giving
you know I've got to look after your
hair and your balls and bath and
everything but when you come to using
only for that because obviously you
tried the Great and the good as wellness
there's a bit of time you've you
something you've been like Winnie I've
gone to you bar I mean I have a friend
who's very into wellness who has put
leeches on
I swear I would never do that that is
too far funny that's a beach too far
okay final product okay oh the GEEP
medicine bag oh the goop medicine bag
okay so these are crystals you have a
little booklet here which tells you what
they do like sodalite
is for healthy communication quartz is
for grounding what should go to crystal
I like amethyst it's good for sleep some
kind of grounding in meditation thank
you so much gonna pop show you probably
get my wellness of course I'm so honored
that you came by
thank you we covered everything from
vibrators we did that's that's this fact
yeah
[Music]